this ring is gorgeous it's um it's over  100 years old what we actually the  diamonds from the 1890s in the setting  is from 1915 which is the year my  grandfather just born I had to dig it  out of a grave but congratulations why  did this happen  several months ago we just been kind of  quietly been quietly enjoying it and we  did decide that Comic Con we were gonna  wear I was gonna wear the ring out in  public and my little joke is because we  were boyfriend/girlfriend on the show  everything I I spend in the marriage  will be a tax write-off up top it can be  you can be frugal and romantic be done  no congratulations if you're standing up  and as a what thank you so much you guys  have a great day excited for your  comic-con thank you I'm so excited for  you this you guys got the scoop  you